it's a great pleasure to to be here at
Columbia Kenny invited me about the time
he took this this new job and it's just
taken a while to get all of us in the
same place and we've been joking with
him he was one of the first PhD students
in our UCLA program when when I came
which is more years ago than probably
either Kenny and I are willing to admit
at this point Columbia is a great place
to be not only for the fine University
and the history of the library and
library school program here but to be
able get people from Rutgers from Pratt
from NYU also I in addition to the cover
of the book librarians always like
artifacts so here's a real copy of the
artifact it doesn't save a bit of
oxymoronic to write hardcover books
about issues of scholarship but it
certainly led to a number of speaking
invitations to different audiences and I
think that's been one of the real
pleasures I mean that's all the
pleasures of the information field is
you get to be a librarian one day an
astronomer the next and art historian
the next and I've been able to move
around to a number of different
audiences Kenny Lee pleased to know I've
actually spoken in law school twice this
year and once to the management school I
think which is an indication of the
number of the arrange of policy issues
and in the broad interest that we're
getting nowadays so let me just kind of
jump right in
I'll talk for a little bit under an hour
if I go straight through but I'm very
happy to take questions as we go and
jump in and keep the dialogue going and
I have no doubt that will spark enough
questions to keep a pretty good
discussion going for a while and then
you promised to some reason some
refreshments at the end I understand
okay so moving right along I think it's
useful to say what's happening here is
not entirely without design there's
certainly some push and some pull but
these notions of cyber infrastructure
Esai NC social science research have a
lot of money and policy decisions behind
them the cyber infrastructure term comes
out of the what soon was the Adkins
report led by Dan Adkins that came out
of NSF in early 2003 east science is the
term that Britain uses for their large
science program that's the more dominant
term in Europe and elsewhere
IRRI searches is getting to be a
collective term that subsumes under
these many different areas
if you look around NSF and look around
the different subject areas you'll find
almost everything he geology engineering
I haven't found a law but I found almost
everything else under some some term
like that so what is it the general goal
is to support these new kinds of
research that they're being called
almost a fourth paradigm of very
distributed very data and information
intensive and the idea that you can use
other people's data as well as your own
in a collective mix-up mash up kind of
way in this environment that we tend to
work in very distributed ways we tend to
collaborate we have virtual
organizations and we tend to work across
across disciplines this is an NSF
picture of what cyber infrastructure
looks like I started this book while on
sabbatical at the Oxford internet
Institute in 2004-2005 and that at that
point the East science was well moving
along in Britain I got to sit on the
management board of E science at Oxford
which really gave me a wonderful insight
access to things they launched their
East social science programme that year
and they also launched the digital
curation Center and if you're not
familiar with the digital curation
Center there's a journal it goes with
that there's a series of conferences
it's a very nice focal point for
bringing together some of the expertise
around digital topics and digital
scholarship so it's a lot of names but
they tend to mean roughly the same thing
this is another nice diagram again for
those of you like more graphic
orientations of these things and this is
in the book as well and it comes out of
a joint us-uk endeavor we're investing
largely at this bottom level and have
for a very long time of being able to
build all of those processors that
physical network that that internet
librarians and archivists are most
interested in that top layer what's
what's the content what goes in the
libraries what goes in the archives of
the publications is it data whatever it
is the stuff in the middle just tends to
get called middle where you know it's a
domain name system and various other
process and services I've never found a
very good definition for it but then
we've got these things that sort of cut
vertically through it what's in that
content layer we've got all these
documents the kinds of things that
librarians and archivists historically
have dealt with the formal publications
we've always had these more semi formal
ones but it's only fairly recently that
we've gotten them where there's this
digital trace of of everything so part
of what's changed is that so much of
what was kind of water-cooler hallway
conversations now gets captured
digitally so we're getting this richer
model this richer environment that we
can have the unpublished material the
websites the blogs are picking up and I
understand who is our tweeter who's in
the room that Barrett there at the very
back I I've given talks in second life
before this is the first time I've been
tweeted live I think this is this is the
first my students sometimes do it from
the classroom which is a little bit
annoying but then you also sometimes get
breaking news back from them from from
their tweets coming along the way this
audience here I think is pretty
sophisticated about what's happening
with scholarly publishing open access
and such I'll spend some time on that
but I want to spend more time on data
because I think that's really the
breaking or the breaking edge they'll
deleting bleeding areas and the ones
that that we're working on these four
categories are from the long-lived
Data Report how many of you have seen
that report those of you like from CSUN
who work in the data area will know that
okay that would the lead author on that
was Chris Greer who's also the one who
wrote that data chapter for the vision
report that came out of that and is also
the one behind the day
that initiative which is now in the
first funding cycles of it that's a very
influential report because of the kinds
of definitions it has in as well as
laying a nice policy framework but he
laid out these four categories of
observational data computational
experimental and records which I think
is a nice one to let us sort of chew on
at the different kinds of things now
we've also got composite objects we've
got new technologies like the object
reuse and exchange initiative which is
part of the open archives initiative
which is a way that you can start to
assert relationships between things so
we're getting lots of stuff out there
but what we would like to do is to be
able to pull it together in a chain
we're pretty good at pulling things
together if they've got bibliographic
citations between them now you can look
at something with cited you can click on
that and move to it and move that but
we're not very good yet at being able to
move from the grant proposal to the talk
to the conference paper to the data and
those are the kinds of things that we
would like to be able to pull together
and the O re technologies are one of the
first things that will help us do that
I've got a couple examples in here of
where you're seeing some things like in
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey where
you've got much more direct link say
between the documents and the data and
you can move between them and that I
think is the environment that we're
starting to move to move into and we
would like to do that across different
kinds of environments and move out of
these these silos that we have and that
the silos are part of the problem one of
my colleagues at UCLA recently said we
don't have silos we have columns of
excellence
and that that that term quickly stuck so
I think we it's interoperability between
columns of excellence that we have to
work on but it's certainly one it's
environment so there's a lot of there's
both push and there's others pull the
distribute access to content and
computing that's that's been coming up
for a while we're getting much more
intense and distributed access the data
deluge if anything is what's caused this
this next big wave and for place like
Wired magazine to declare our research
methods to be dead you can just go out
and mine the data I've got some slides
farther on from sins the Center for
embedded Network sensing that our big
research center that we're part of where
we've got little in-situ sensors all
over the environment we can look at
everything from earthquakes to water
quality to bird nesting behavior using
these technologies but if you also look
at things like the Large Hadron Collider
the sort of things going on in astronomy
the data are coming out at faster rates
that you can actually store them if
you're working on high energy physics
you're putting up filters to say of
everything coming off this data stream
give me whatever matches this filter and
the rest of it you're throwing on the
floor
okay so we're already at this real
deluge environment and people would like
to have their own copies of the data in
a few areas but in in all realism
there's more data being produced and can
be managed so we're getting more tools
we're getting more services in this
environment we've got this also pull of
virtual organizations that's a term that
NSF uses goes back to the early
collaboratory days but we would like to
leverage these investments in research
not just to be able to replicate
experiments replicate studies but we
would like to be able to ask new
questions of old data we'd like to be
able to compare things across say all of
the different Mediterranean climates
around the world we'd like to know what
happened in this fresh water environment
compared to this fresh water environment
East Coast West Coast other parts of the
world and what's happening
and then lastly it's not it's not
without coincidence
that we've got this cultural
contribution that people want to
contribute things whether to YouTube
whether to Twitter whether to Flickr and
other kinds of environments that we're
also moving into open access publishing
and we'll talk about that more in a few
minutes as well this is from your
website and it's nice to see that you
have a huge presence here on campus
although I'm told it's a much more
decentralized environment than one would
get a feel for from this you know the
wonderful story beautiful central campus
but that you've got the NIH public
policy up top you're working with
faculty on the open access issues you've
got the research repositories so
universities are getting very quickly
engaged you'll find very similar things
at UCLA and other major research
environments this is a report that came
out last month
so station of research libraries and
several other partners coalition who
networked information American
universities nostalgic which has just
changed its name to something which I
might with a much simpler acronym that I
have have yet to remember I clipped out
a couple of quotes from it faculty
research and scholarship represent
invaluable intellectual capital but the
value that capitalized and it's
effective dissemination to present and
future audiences so we're thinking about
you know what does that dissemination
mean it's locked up how can you reuse it
and their primary recommendation is the
campuses should do exactly as Columbia
is doing is initiating discussions
involving the administration the faculty
how do we modify practices around
intellectual property kind of thing
you've now got a full-time officer and
again Kenny cruse to to work on and
really engage in the kinds of debates
that we're here to have this afternoon
and as of yesterday we've said farewell
to the print a monograph as well I know
and I'm still publishing you know I said
contract with MIT press what can I say
okay this is inside higher ed which is a
very nice open access daily that
out that has very similar headlines the
Chronicle of Higher Ed but it's a nice
quick update one this is University of
Michigan press is merging into the
library and going to a primarily digital
environment so you can see lots more
deadly I headlines like this so those of
you your MLS students what is this a
famine oh this should be a very familiar
title page what is this yes
that that it is that but it is it is
most importantly the title page of the
first english-language Journal it is
indeed the right the transactions a
physics if occult philosophy
philosophical transactions of the Royal
Society when we're in Britain I got
invited to a meeting at the Royal
Society my husband George kept saying
the Royal Society of what say no the
Royal Society
right well it's like our National
Academy and it's it's still standing and
in fact it's still in the Savoy as well
okay so look look at what's up there
okay
this article transactions giving some
account of the present undertaken
studies and labors of the ingenious in
many parts of the world it has a volume
number volume number one so they intend
it was going to keep on publishing
there's a date on it the years nineteen
or 1665 in 1666 it has an imprint says
where it was published in The Savoy said
who the printers were it located at the
Bell a little without temple bar
printers to the Royal Society okay looks
a lot like what we got today doesn't it
there's the same Journal and what you
can't see in the bottom right corner is
that it says the world's longest running
international science journal it's a lot
prettier unless you really like the old
type but it certainly got all the same
elements there so the point is that you
know some things have changed radically
but a whole lot of things are really
where we were at the very beginning of
printing how do we get here what are the
functions this is a tour of scholarly
communication in in one short slide
there's many models out there of how you
divide up why scholars publish I've
divided up into three categories
legitimization dissemination and then
put access preservation and curation
together in one function in the print
world we legitimize things by peer
review
that's how you get the authority you get
the quality you get the priority you
decide what to trust by peer review and
that that goes back a very long way but
it goes back to Francis Bacon or
arguably even back to st. Augustine
it's not science it's not scholarship
until it's reviewed by your peers and
accepted into the environment you want
to disseminate your works you'll make
people aware of them
the publishers did that authors did the
bit with preprint distribution copy to
mail things the access the preservation
and the curation and curations the more
active term have been done by the
library and there's our lovely
neo-gothic paulo library built very in
the center of campus now the
undergraduate library what do we do in a
digital world
well the main thing that's different is
it's digital we still do the peer review
we still needed set dissemination
disseminate it it's this bottom right
corner that's changed the most the
library still plays a key role but
rather than the library getting those
physical documents and storing them
locally largely them but the digital
materials are remaining on the
publishers server and we're leasing
access to is a different business model
there we're putting up these
repositories like the with the research
Commons that you're working on here with
with dspace and understand moving to to
fedora sometimes people put them up on
their home pages but there's other ways
that they get they get disseminated so
that the the real change is down here in
this bottom right corner the motivations
haven't changed that much now let's make
some comparisons to what's happening
with data in this environment okay so
what what are data this screenshot I've
had for a while it's from from Noah and
we're all very pleased at the new head
of Noah Jane Lubchenco is was also
president of Co data and president of
Triple A s so we've got somebody who
really cares about scientific data
and the obama administration in this
cell in this area okay this is a
technical definition that comes from
nasa but it's one that that's very
widely referenced i think it's the one
that's in the that long live data report
as well so it's something that's
reinterpret of all representation it's
formalized and then we've got some
examples of what data might be but in
our world
Dayna are really just alleged evidence
they're not data until somebody makes a
claim about something and the notion of
the notion of the notion of what is
evidence is something goes very deep in
the archives world that goes very deep
in the law world you have to take how
many required courses did you have to
take in evidence to be to become a
lawyer we have a question one big one we
have a question the back here okay I'll
read you the website address or where I
got this from oh this is from the oceans
this is from ORNL Oak Ridge National
Labs this particular one so I I don't
own this but usually if you at least
give attribution people don't get too
upset if you post them on the websites
so you we will Pope will post these and
some versions these posted elsewhere but
you know feel free to ask anything else
so but the point that I want to make
here is that data is or data are a very
fuzzy concept and in a lot of these
discussions around preserving data
managing data there's an underlying
assumption that data are some kind of
objective facts something you can touch
you know it is when you got it
and that's actually not the case water
data varies hugely from one area to the
next and that's what I'm going to work
through for a few minutes here with some
examples I've got three son for science
data one for social sciences and one for
humanities and I'm trying to make two
contrasting points here one on the left
side oh and one on the right side on the
left side to point out that for each of
the different areas of the sciences and
these are certainly a extremely small
sample what can be data varies widely
within ecology you could come up with a
much longer list certainly within
medicine you can come with a vastly
longer list of what might be data but so
within a field that's part of what you
learn as you become a scholar in a field
of what our what our data what do you
trust on the right is what are the
sources in the sciences you either
generate your own data your observations
your models your experiments or your
records or you might get them from some
other science group but typically you're
working with David were produced either
by a scientific community or for
scientific purposes and here's an
example and this is the Sloan Digital
Sky Survey and one that we're working
with in this new data net data net
project the Sloan is interesting for for
a number of reasons one is that it
instantiates this value chain
they have been scanning the night sky
for about the last 10 years actually a
core to the night sky and it got richer
and richer as time went down this is a
project that is now shutting down and
going into more of an archive mode note
this particular shot that I put up here
is one we can see the publication's more
than 1,700 scholarly publications came
out of this data set so you can look at
a data set find the publication so you
can look at the publications you can go
the datasets the vast majority of use of
this site was by non astronomers very
heavily used by
students very heavily used by amateur
astronomers as well so there's your
value chain you can both go in both
directions with it another thing that's
important by the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey is how it changed the culture of
the of this particular science like many
other sciences people tend to get their
own data and collect it and hold it data
mining meant the data are mine what
Sloane did in Alex Saleh and the late
Jim Gray the Turing Award winner who
disappeared at sea about two years ago
were the the ones behind this they
promised if they got the money from
Sloane they would make the data publicly
available
anybody could mine it and they did and
once they did it and everybody started
using it then it became much harder for
other people to try to protect their own
data because once this got out into the
open so it's one one big project and got
to break the break the back and move
things forward okay jumping ahead to
social science data again notice the
very many different kinds of things that
might be data in the social sciences on
the right he had noticed this contrast
that if you're in areas like sociology
depending on actually depending what
part of sociology you're in you may get
your data on your own you may go out
into your own surveys you might go into
a big social science data archive like
the icpsr at the University of Michigan
you might go into some of the CSUN our
CSUN archives as well to use data but
you might also get things like
government records corporate records
census data you might get data that were
produced for for non-research purposes
so you got it you've already got a
different kind of mix and here is an
example of the one at the UCL at UCLA
our social science data archive the one
at Michigan is actually the largest one
in the world right now so if you have
the money to do a massive social survey
you deposit the data some of these
archive sites go back many many decades
the Michigan one goes look back long
before digitization in the humanities
again on the left many different things
can be data on the right your sources
are rarely going out and observing
people you're much more likely to be
relying on records what's also different
about the humanities is you have a much
fuzzier line between what's a
publication and what's data something
that was written as a novel a hundred
years ago may turn out to be very
important data to it and historian it
may describe people places types of
types of life Lynn brinly the head of
the British Library likes to say that
the 19th century trashy novels when they
digitized those that Trent one of the
most popular things they ever put online
okay in the 1900 census when that was
put online that became very popular very
quickly for other kinds of purposes you
get a much different characteristic in
the humanities of what people use or
what purposes was this a question back
here No
how many of you have seen the Roman
Forum probably okay in person how many
of you have seen the digital roman forum
okay okay so this is a project that
start at UCLA it's now running also at
the University of Virginia because of
Boerne free shooters startup is now the
head of the Institute for Advanced
Technology and humanities at Virginia
then you probably don't think that this
was taken by a digital camera at 480
right okay no it's a complete
reconstruction and again it's a nice
example of the value chain because
behind this is a wide array of
scholarship around what they think
occurred at the different places at
different points in time and you can
move a slider along you can move through
different political periods you can move
through different architectural period
signed Favreau an architectural
historian in our architecture school is
part of this project as well and you can
see when it was a temple when it was a
marketplace as big bibliographies behind
it you can see what's contested on the
different places so the digital
humanities are really moving along very
very quickly and sophisticated ways in
this environment so how did data get
into the value chain this is a
deliberately forced force comparison
between them to point out how much less
mature we are at dealing with data and
and as we confront getting them into
repositories this is a lot of the issues
that that we're facing we don't have a
lot of practice for legitimizing them
what articles are submitted for peer
review the peer reviewers will say you
know is do I do I trust this author does
it look like the data support the
arguments is or faithful living to it
but only in a few fields do people
really go back and redo the proofs or
expected to go back to original sources
the dissemination very commonly is by
things being described in a publication
somebody talked about their data set I
sentiment
male Simba phone call will you share
your data with me and similarly the
access is getting it from the author
repositories whether they are
repositories by discipline things like
the the protein databank the iris for
seismology or you know various other
fields or university ones are
particularly important here because it
gives you a place to get the peer review
somebody to test-drive the data as one
of the people said it one of the codata
meetings is the metadata adequate does
it does it meet usual standards you've
got a publisher for it and you've got a
place you can get either immediate
access or to some kind of embargoes and
the embargo is vary by field things like
five years in areas of Medicine two
years in seismology six months in some
other areas and the embargoes let the
authors maintain their priority so they
get the first rate of publication but
also encourages them to publish fast
enough so it gets out there for other
people to use so that that's how some of
the the intellectual property issues are
dealt with in this for these purposes
now let me to a bit of a detour and give
you an example from our own research you
can see about the these very fuzzy
notions of data we have been an NSF
science technology center since 2002
we've been renewing our second five
years of funding and we put and I'll
show you a picture in a moment we have
these wonderful sensors that we put all
over the world around us on the far side
you will see the list of the technology
areas the we've got about 200 people in
the center's scattered across these five
universities and the majority of them 70
or 80 percent of them are working in
these technology areas they're either
actually building sensor systems they're
looking at the technology around how you
trigger the sensing some of them are
looking at sort of network health
statistical work and then we're part of
statistics and data practices team we're
working in a number of different
scientific application areas ecology
to transport water and his urban sensing
I've now got a doctoral student working
with the cell phones we've got cell
phones from Nokia and others and you can
track your way in the world look at your
green footprint you can look at your
diet so it's but it's the potentially
the world's largest surveillance system
so we're looking at very interesting
privacy issues and such around the use
of cell phones this is a few of what our
sensors look like we've got ones you can
stick down in the water
we've got ones on a the Robo duck that
goes around there's our helicopter it
flies around with sensors on them we've
got this the robot that works 3d in the
forest canopy until we had this you had
to build physical scaffolds if if any of
you know about flux net and the carbon
flux work which the big Observatory
networks very important for a global
climate change they build these big
stationary networks we've got things we
could cut a transect across a river we
did a very nice project where we looked
at where the Merced River comes out of
Yosemite and the San Joaquin comes out
of the dirty agricultural Valley and you
look at how they're mixing in that
environment and until we could do this
kind of work the only way you could
really look at that River mixing was to
have a bunch of graduate students in a
canoe with buckets and a stopwatch okay
so it's really pretty amazing but the
new kinds of data that they were able to
get with this this is just one of the
the number of studies that we've done in
this area or an NSF Center we're
supposed to share data so we're asking
when I ask you naive questions like well
what are the data and who might you be
willing to share them with under what
circumstances and what do we need to
know about the data and how do
metadata around it and there's a lot of
implications about the architecture of
pulling these things together and then
leveraging these resources in different
environments and the students working
with me on this at backgrounds they have
Miis degrees or they have archives
background but I've also got them from
from the domain Sciences as well I've
got someone from physics and other one
from Cal Tech engineering people from
biology art and a very nice mix working
on this ok so we ask people things like
you know what are your data and the
techni the engineers will tell you
temperatures temperature we've put our
sensors out there we look at temperature
you ask a biologist you get things like
this you get there's a hundred ways to
measure temperature you get the
biologists who don't trust what the
engineers are doing and have set up
three different temperature sensors next
to each other at 5,000 feet and the
James reserve and until those have run
for 365 days straight they're not going
to trust the calibration on okay so in
terms of designing our systems we need
to know who cares about what kinds of
data this is another one of my favorite
ones that came out of this and it's
worth spending a minute on we were able
to categorize these different varieties
of data when people say what are the
data coming off the networks it's
usually the stuff in the middle that
they're they're thinking about it's the
humidity it's the water it's the flow
it's a connectivity the wind speed
actually what's really coming off of
these is microvolts and you've got to
take the microvolt through some kind of
model before you know if it's ammonia or
co2 or calcium or pH level or those
various other kinds of things okay so
that's coming off the sensors then
you've got the environmental scientists
the biologists out in the field dipping
things out of the water picking stuff up
out of the dirt they're doing wet labs
in the field they're getting these other
things at the bottom to compare and
calibrate for where they trust the stuff
in the middle over here in the purple on
the Left we've got these robotics guys
who are moving that road
duck around moving that helicopter
around and moving that other thing to 3d
space the nihms and they need to know
rudder angle and motor speed because
there they need to move the thing around
to know the next interesting place to
pick up data from about the environment
and then over here on the right we've
got a lot of Engineers there trying to
make the whole network function and they
need to know about battery life it turns
out the first three years of sins the
majority of papers were about battery
life it took a long time before
technology was stable enough so you
really had something looking like
scientific data and then then people
start getting worried about bitter rot
but not until they got the point they
have stable battery life here now these
are all being collected by different
people they're going into different
databases how do you bring these back
together again so somebody next year
somebody from a different group can
figure out what those data in the midle
mean okay but that's the kind of thing
that we're concerned about in this
environment so why should people share
whether their data or their publications
well why should they contribute to this
cyber infrastructure so as I said you've
got the general we're here to share it's
not science it's not scholarship until
somebody's had a peer review we're
supposed to get out there we want to be
recognized by our peer look at our
publications we want to collaborate with
other people and often that's what we
collaborate about and right up front you
have your data manager plans and say we
call it we produce these data together
we all have access to them who has the
rights to them at the end of the project
reciprocity you might share them with
other people that you're not directly
collaborating with and lastly is good
old coercion we've got a lot more
carrots than sticks in a khadeem but if
your funding agency says you're not
getting the last payment on your grant
until you post your data well that
that's coercion you're starting to see
that more in Europe than you are then
you are here but you are starting to see
requirements for data management plans
into into grant proposals so there's a
certainly a social change going on in
this environment and we're seeing a lot
of change now in this general open
access area and open access it's not
just about let's bring down the
publishers and that's certainly how the
publishers are are reacting to it but I
think more importantly it's about
interoperability if you we're really
going to have truly open science and
open scholarship but if we're going to
get some links across these these
columns of excellence
we can't have them all locked up in
proprietary formats and formats that are
really too deeply bound in individual
disciplines it did you can't get between
them so this is where we're concerned
about you know how do you mix it up how
do you mash it up how do you avoid
getting locked in to one technology one
ontology one one different structure and
bringing them together so that the sort
of share and share alike is what I think
is really what driving this but we're
definitely searching for business models
that they're not yet clear and that was
one things that we discussed over lunch
I noticed that you have already put up a
Creative Commons license on your Scotty
communication website you're right up
front right up front with that how many
of you have posted anything of your own
putting a Creative Commons license on it
a few of you how many of you found the
Creative Commons tool that's now
available for Microsoft Word nobody ok
remember I mentioned the East science
initiative in the UK run by Tony hay for
which the Queen gave him a New Year's
Honours as OBE or OBE or Commander which
I think Rico started after he's acted I
think he had to be a sir she did he's
not a sir yet he's one step below sir
okay below that but when he got his his
handshake from the Prince and where you
going next I'm going to Microsoft
Tony hey is now
of technical computing for Microsoft
he's a very big open access advocate and
he has set up a scholarly communication
program to get more tools for scholars
also to make it easier to do these kinds
of open access things you can now put a
plug in it doesn't work on the max yet
works on the PCs you can put a plug into
your PC based Microsoft words you can
put a creative license right on your
document as you create it okay and so
many of the difficulties of getting
people to cooperate put things
repositories is that barrier to entry
and they're trying to build tools to
lower that barrier denters a lot of
contractual issues lots of other things
how many of you have used the
sherpa/romeo site ah good okay but not
to men not to many I'm surprised at how
few people know this this was put up by
the additionally with a project of the
British funding under JISC and some
others is now now broadened you have
many more rights than you realize when
you publish things or you can also
assert your rights up front if you go to
sherpa/romeo you can type in the name of
a publisher or type in the name of a
journal and you can quickly see what
your rights are in terms of being able
to republish to post things preprints
post prints and so on make sure all my
students know about sherpa/romeo again
lots more action this is what a week or
two ago March 12th the NIH after much
wrangling the deposit law was then
folded into the new stimulus package
that's gone forward yesterday actually
this morning's news on MIT through MIT
following Harvard all this is dated
March 20th some people at university of
california are quite perturbed that we
actually had a policy that looks like
Harvard's about two years earlier but a
guy caught up in internal wrangling but
the wonderful faculty governance of UC
means it takes a very long time to get
something sorted out but it got it got
bogged down in implementation issues but
you know we we we are working our way
forward in that in that direction so
there's a lot of action on this front
you see also got out in front
building one repository for all 10
campuses and this is this is four or
five years old already and but 27,000
paper is actually not very many for 10
campuses of UC so there's still there's
still some progress going there but we
did put all of the sins publications
into a part of a part of building
together our own life cycle so we can
experiment and put these pieces in and
we've got eight hundred publications in
and I think within six months we had
eight thousand downloads on them and it
really does expose them very quickly
and the majority of those come through
Google Scholar that's where most of the
hits are because it's only am i
compliant they get picked up that way
not only do you get more citations but
you get a monthly report of uses usage
statistics on your publication so this
is nice for for anyone's ego you can
quickly get a monthly report of saying
who is down low or how many of your
things have been downloaded this month
and and to date this is one from October
just a few of ours that came through and
we've now posted our sins publications
in there okay so progress but again
we're not quite there yet there's a
whole you know the technology is always
a lot easier than the policy or than the
behavior change and this one we're
moving forward there's part even sent us
to people not to share we still get
rewarded for publishing things nobody
ever got tenure for writing really good
metadata not yet anyway but that's you
know it may change but it's going to
take a while and it's going to be a lot
easier to get things in it's much harder
to document your data in ways that other
people can make sense of it than it is
to document it if you're just using it
by yourself or in your own laboratory
although people will certainly give you
plenty of tales of how when the postdoc
graduate or post I left the lab those
data could never be found again or
interpret it again so if you do document
them if you do get processes going in
your lab or in your team you're much
more likely to make use of them within
your own
group and we're trying to encourage
people under those reasons if no other
competition a priority of claims if you
deposit your data then you don't have it
to barter with anybody else anymore okay
but on the other hand if you're in a
field where you've got a culture of
sharing then maybe if you don't share
your data and nobody else going to share
their data with you either
okay so there's it's shifting a bit but
it varies from one to another the
priority of claims is is being dealt
with with things like the embargo
periods and those are being worked out
within individual fields and last thing
we can go into much more detail but in
discussion probably should around some
of the intellectual property issues and
these vary considerably between the
sciences the Social Sciences and the
humanities and the arts and they're
they're two sided they're they're both
people wanting to control their own
resources and in getting access to other
people's resources so it's um you it
would be lovely if you could keep
everything of your own and not release
the pitch you could have everybody
else's and of course it doesn't work
that way we've got it some reciprocity
in this environment if anything it's the
most difficult in the humanities because
they're so reliant on intellectual
property held by other people john
Unsworth who shared the Commission on
cyber infrastructure for the humanities
and social sciences said it's going to
be difficult to write the history of the
20th century because the historians
can't get their hands on the data ok
right on the records so clear
definitions of data are part of the
problem it's nice to have a data
management plan but then you've got
agree what what the day if you look at
the fine print in your NSF or NIH
contract you'll find it's it's really
even there it's not clear what they mean
by the data when they say you need to
you need to share it and then there's
lots of contractual issues that I'm sure
Kenny has the answer to absolutely
particularly when you move across
jurisdictions and the EU is is dealing
with this as well now let me take yet
one more detour before I come back and
I'll try to pull all of this back
together and that is the the
cyberlearning report which was mentioned
earlier
don't try to deal with that funny little
one URL up there just Google fostering
fostering learning in the networked
world that it'll pop right up it's on
it's on the NSF NSF website you may
recognize some of these names dan Adkins
again the one that did the cyber
infrastructure report put this to put
this task force together I had the
privilege of sharing it you may notice
how Abelson is the head of the open
courseware initiative at MIT Lee Dirk's
had scholarly communication program at
Microsoft
Clifford Lynch well known for coalition
networked information Diana Oakland
jurist president educause Mike Smith
Marshall Smith was the head of protocol
programs at Hewlett Foundation that
funded the open educational resources
initiative and and the open courseware
initiative and he was Clinton's
education adviser he's now back in the
Obama administration and I just got an
email from his office today wanting to
pursue some of this further as well okay
Alex Ali is the astronomer over the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey so it was a
six-month hit and run task force as they
called us to try to advise NSF on what
they should do about cyber learning
where they should invest the motivation
here is that we've built this rich
infrastructure for research how can we
leverage it for learning again that NSF
vision document looks at the workforce
requirements how do we get a new
workforce in scholarship that
understands how to work with cyber
infrastructure that's what that was much
more learning about cyber infrastructure
this is learning with cyber
infrastructure there's some nice
scenarios in here about how kids should
grow up being able to use their
technologies to peer to peer learning
inside classrooms and outside classrooms
we're looking at cated gray there's no
reason your kids
- turd might not be in China or in India
he or she does not have to be down the
street we also said that why is it that
we make kids check their technology at
the door before they go in the classroom
and turn everything off any technology
that powerful is one we should actually
make manifest for learning rather than
prohibit it so we're looking for ways
that we could bring these technologies
into into much more learning
environments okay why is it important
well it leverages people's learning
skills and also capacity here we are
radically cutting back on universities
freezing positions cutting faculty lines
cutting support for things and yet the
predictions are that as many as a
hundred million students are going to
have demand for higher education over
the next decade Hewlett Foundation says
you'd have to establish a new university
a week to meet up with the coming demand
that is simply not going to happen
similarly we're not going to deck out
wet labs in every High School in this
country or around the world we've got to
find ways to take better advantage of
the technologies that we have to improve
learning to bring people together over
time we are very careful not to say that
technology is the answer to education
rather it is an answer there's much more
than we that can be done and the things
like the scholarly data we're producing
for research should also be made useful
for educational purposes so these
repositories that we're building we need
to think of as education repositories
rather than just as research
repositories what changes the way that
you think about them so just briefly why
NSF did this we thought we were they at
a particular inflection point that the
technologies were mature enough we
understood enough about learning that
this was a time that we could really
take advantage of technology and move
forward we were commissioned from both
cyber infrastructure and education has
to look at these questions across all of
the areas of NSS man
date with the dotted lines as arts and
humanities are outside their
responsibilities but it's certainly
still relevant to those areas and given
who's on the task force you won't be
surprised that we asked we said we need
to promote open educational resources
okay
that was certainly a foregone conclusion
of who was asked to come together for
this but again it was it's the mix-up
and the mash-up that the you know the
fortunes have been invested in
educational tools that don't live beyond
the end of the grant project because
they're proprietary tools nobody
maintains them they're too big they're
too small you can't mix them together
they don't fit a common platform they
don't plug-and-play
we had a number of recommendations in
that area so I would encourage you to
take a look at that report and that
reports being picked up by other
countries very very quickly and the the
transition team was in the NSF offices
very early on as it was about as
friendly to this new administration as
you could possibly want okay so let me
try to wrap this up with three texts
have text-heavy slides but give you some
context here and these are to think
about the new scholarly infrastructure
in terms of the concerns of scholars of
the public and of universities so in
terms of scholars the publication issues
that you know I've gone through quite a
bit already these are the kinds of
things about authorship issues being
worked out
everybody wants peer review peer reviews
is changing but you know it's still it
still remains the gold standard and
different kinds of issues around
intellectual property and dissemination
are what's really going to drive us the
data sharing issues are much less well
understood and are the messiest of all
we've been working we've had a section
teeth I'm active in at American
Association Advancement of science we've
had several sessions there around some
of these issues and these are the kinds
of things that the scholarly communities
are chewing on of how do you get
agreement
among the research of partners how do
you get agreements within disciplines
between disciplines and deal with the
technology and the policy to facilitate
because we really do have columns of
excellence all over the place in this in
this environment the public has concerns
as well and that's part of what's
driving the open access movement is that
for publicly funded research people
would like to have access to the to the
products of of that research what does
that mean how do you get the data how do
you get the publications at what time in
what place the foundations even in the
US have widely varying requirements of
our NSF has been reluctant to make as
many declarations around data sharing as
NIH has the cyber infrastructure program
all the programs have their external
advisory committees the that one has
both Tony hay and Brewster Kahle the
head of Internet Archive on it and they
manage to get into the minutes of the
last meeting a real strong push for
getting more open access to the products
of NSF research into NSF but it's an
uphill battle there as well and what is
open access what does it was really mean
particularly in an area of bayh-dole
which is what 25 or so years old now
where you you can patent and license
things out of university research what
are the deposit rules what is licensing
of when it when it says a reasonable fee
what what does a reasonable fee mean and
does any of that go back to the library
how do you use the data in publications
for your teaching and for your learning
rights for educational reuse we've got
there's some very interesting
intellectual property issues buried in
there as well around things like the the
FERPA laws and being able to post
posters
and then lastly on the university
concerns and we talked a bit over lunch
about some of these and universities
trying to plan cyber infrastructure at
the campus level and deal with these
kinds of you know peer-to-peer moving
big datasets around the campus make data
and other publications available for
student use and so on there's a lot of
things that they look like unfunded
mandates and you know a data management
plan to a lot of researchers means I
will give it to the library and the
libraries are getting wise and saying
let's kind of work with people up front
and sort out what what does that really
mean and at what point do you have a
data management plan the campuses are
concerned and we're dealing with this at
you with this at UCLA if we've got data
that's got a repository within a
discipline if it's already going to go
to the protein databank if it's going to
go someplace else in in medicine fine
we're happy it's the data that don't
have a home that people are much more
concerned about and what universities
should be should be maintaining who's
going to maintain that orphaned data
once someone decides it's worth curating
and maintaining we talked a bit about
the open access and the business models
problem and what open data really means
is open data a term that's familiar
people's was coined by Peter Marie rust
in chemistry at Cambridge University
it's it's an important point and one
that I didn't get into here what the
chemistry field is it's particularly
concerned about is keeping the data in
structured form the chemists are very
sophisticated about sending automated
agents and robots out around the
internet and they want to collect up
everything about their particular
molecule ative whatever their compound
is that those of interest to them and if
it's in a structured form they can find
it if it's locked up in a PDF it becomes
useless to them and you just flattened
out all of that nice rich data structure
so the pushrod open data is to keep the
data
in a format that's actually useful
useful and structured so that's a
different kind of issue then open access
and open data are not the same thing and
then can we get educationally used to
those research data we did an
interesting project under the digital
libraries initiative in the area of
geography and trying to repurpose
people's scientific data as people's
research data back into the classroom
and that turned out to be much much
harder to do than anyone ever
anticipated course management systems
again we talked about this a bit over
lunch
UCLA realized that we had 26 different
course management systems around the
campus and the library was trying to do
its reserve systems linking up with all
of them so the library was going nuts
over this but it was really the
undergraduate students that that pushed
most loudly for change because they were
faced with a different course management
system for every single class they took
and this is an area where and you know
as the current ministration says no no
good crisis should go to waste
is it's a chance to get people to work
together and we are making progress we
got people to standardize under an
opt-in model on Moodle is an open access
course management system and that allows
us then to share the expertise because
with 26 different systems you had 26
different staff and you know so you
didn't have people you couldn't have a
campus-wide helpdesk so that so again
that's the opt-in model to get to get
the partnership and that's taking off
even working on governance models you're
working on business models and we're
making some progress in that environment
but it's it's one of many uphill areas
so I've got a lot of policy roles that
we're going to deal with around
intellectual property and publication
and and virtual organizations in fact
that's virtual organizations is the area
of our current research looking at
scientific practices around different
kinds of cyber infrastructure
organizations and then I will let you
decide whether you think that library is
rising or
anybody's seen that it's a public
sculpture anybody seen that one it's in
Melbourne Australia it's a wonderful
okay okay so with that let me stop and
put up our sponsorship for this we're
getting most of our research is funded
by the National Science Foundation
through sins and then Microsoft has been
supporting some of the work around the
open room around our open access to data
and data visualization and handheld
computing and such as well so thank you
but I figured that would provoke a few
good discussions I'd start back here
well that was a simple question let me
see if I can summarize that briefly for
the for the video is I mean you're
asking a large number of questions about
the the Phyllis the philosophy and and
theory of of learning and how that
changes in this environment and who
should really be involved in it
I mean I mean you're saying that the
technology is cold I don't think I would
agree the technology is cold and it's
not the technology is not in certainly
not entirely neutral but it's you know
it is neutral to a certain certain
degree about what what is that we choose
to do with it link librarians our new
generation of librarians and archivists
is going to have to be as facile with
educational tools as as with research
tools so yes I think this is something
that our field needs to be very much
very much engaged in when you look at
how particularly young people are
engaged in social networking how much
they rely on Facebook on Twitter on
Flickr and the way they communicate with
with their friends it's been passing to
us just to watch how things move through
you know through the through the next
generation you
might have a phone call with one person
your family and then you get an hour
later you got a phone call from somebody
else said so-and-so updated their
Facebook page and they told me so and so
was in the hospital they didn't get it
because I called them they didn't get it
because I sent them an email message
that's the way they're communicating and
it's moving back through these different
environments so if that's a comfortable
environment for people to learn and
people to communicate why shouldn't that
be a comfortable environment for them to
learn in man and that environment is
being used for almost everything except
except learning we've got some of the
people on this panel like Roy Peay at
Stanford Marshall Lin at Berkeley Ken
Kendra at carnegie-mellon there they're
teaching physics in world of warcraft
and they're getting kids really really
engaged and they're teaching real real
physics lessons real chemistry lessons
they're also doing a mixed technology
amidst environments it's not that you
just go have an avatar go live in Second
Life there's some very nice ones at
Marshall Lynn likes to talk about where
you put probe we attach a probe to the
computer so you might work with your cat
with your chemicals and you stick the
probe into a beaker and now you can
graph it okay so you see you've got a
mix of what's going on in the physical
world around you you've got tools in in
the technical environment
it's these really mixed-media kinds of
places that I think we're going to play
in and live in in the next generation it
was that that was a long answer to a
long question I could take and do some
shorter answers to over here on the left
excellent question let's see if I can
summarize it briefly so the questions
about cloud computing and in commodity
services for for for cloud computing
such as Amazon and Google was briefly
providing and then and then withdrew
from that mark which was which was
pretty interesting that they got into it
for six months and then got back out of
it right that would I thought I would I
thought I'd try to repeat it and then
explain it because if there was oh
there's a lot of a lot of jargon here
and there was also a very good session
just in last month in February at
triple-a s with Tony hey Ian foster of
fostering Kesselman the grid and some
but one of one of fosters colleagues
from Argonne National Labs you might
want to look at that dealt that whole
set of questions ok so cloud computing
is I mean it's some kind of sometimes
seen as analogous with the grid which
you know another good jargony term think
of it as instead of say client-server
computing where we've got using this PC
as a client and a server say the
repository of Columbia University think
of a whole network an Amazon or Google
size Network
and you cease to run your old own data
centers here on campus you outsource
that the commodity services is you start
to outsource to a whole set of servers
out there so instead of buying a cluster
computers you you simply buy cycles and
the service is already that will let you
put in a credit card and say I need this
many cycles right now okay and then some
people are really promoting that as the
way to go and there's a lot there's a
lot of green issues also I mean even in
SF is starting to say the the power
consumption on computing is going to
kill us okay so the power consumption is
now a real engineering issue and in a
competition issue and campuses are
trying to so this is a campus it's
probably a campus cyber infrastructure
problem of every new investigator were
like his or her own cluster why don't we
have a smaller number of bigger clusters
with an expert staff around campus and
but then how do you get that into your
grant to say I'm going to buy cycles on
this campus cluster rather than I'm
going to run my own cluster that I
control there's a lot of proprietary
intellectual property issues around it
back on your commodity point because
once you put your data out there do you
really know nobody else is looking at it
I mean that the grid computing came out
of an academic environment where there
weren't so many proprietary issues and
it's one thing if I take cycles off my
another scientist computer but does GM
want to take cycles off Honda's
computers or vice versa and have their
cycles running in what could be a more
public environment so it's the
proprietary issues economically it
sounds like it makes sense but it's do
do I trust you and do I trust Amazon and
are my data really safe though that
that's what that's where the discussion
is going and the Google was pushing free
services just give us your data and what
will take care of it for you boy this
made academics and particularly
University librarians
really really nervous is it still going
to be there and sure enough six months
later they decide it wasn't good
business model and poof okay so let's
hope you weren't really counting on that
for the long term so no you've raised a
host of really challenging questions and
they're bleeding edge away it was a very
it was quite to turn out the last did
they like the last session of the last
day of triple a SP always stayed over to
here because of the big names are
talking about just that set of issues
other questions okay
like any necessarily copyright but just
policy law external forces in general
you you alluded to many of them and many
of them conflict with some of the goals
of the players on and what we have here
or many of them allow choices but those
choices have to be deliberately made you
know how do you see decision making what
would you recommend
really for decision making on so many of
the issues that you've covered to be
able to respond to those policy legal
external forces get a lawyer and you
deal these two lawyers in town to have
any business right now so so Kenny's
question is about how you deal with with
with the real mechanisms of working out
what what like say are there come
they're competing interests and in some
ways they're they're competing interest
to the very open academic values as well
in substantive scholarship goals etc
somebody needs to make decision
about how to interplay with these forces
and who's going to make those decisions
yeah I mean this is really this is
really endemic and of course that's you
get this in education you get this in
any other kind of research area so these
are syste they're so systemic and you
can't get it you can't get it out of
them all the one so you push here
something's gonna pop out over there
we're already wrestling with this around
the tenure and promotion system how do
you value work that's really digital in
nature and the humanities are dealing
with this as much as anybody has and
they've been working on it for for a
good long while I think that they're
making some progress II used to be
nobody could get could get tenure doing
digital work in the humanities and now
we flow to digital humanities faculty
position 300 people showed up for it
we've got a real ogre now got it we've
now got a digital humanities manifesto
that do under mellon funding no less at
UCLA trying to move forward so so I mean
some of us going to be whoever chooses
to take leadership it's going to be as
but it's I think it's going to happen
sort of one decision time it's going to
happen around whatever those committees
are that make the tenan promotion
decisions and it's it's one thing to
start out over lunch it's going to also
happen in areas like how to indirect
costs get allocated so indirect costs
that the cost so when you get when you
apply to NSF or NIH for a grant whatever
the university's indirect cost rate is
ours is I think 54 percent so if I want
a hundred thousand dollars to spend I
need to ask NSF for a hundred and fifty
four thousand dollars and that only
fifty four goes back to UCLA and part of
it is supposed to go to research
infrastructure part of its supposed to
go libraries part of the coast of
technology and so on what's what's the
indirect cost rate at Columbia 61 okay
so they're big numbers a lot of money
there so maybe that's you know some of
that money may go into author fees for
open access journals as opposed to going
into subscription fees some of it may go
into data management you know data
management resources
so those are those are things may get
worked out - they're certainly being
fought out on the advisory committees
around the funding agencies and they're
being worked out within universities I
can tell you for a for example at UCLA
with our biggest you know center for
embedded Network sensing UCLA really
wanted an NSF STC it's sort of a big
badge of honor to to get one of these
and went all out to get it but that
means if you bring your grants in
through this SDC your Dean doesn't get
the overhead that you know the overhead
goes there okay and you know as long as
those make any difference to mine I look
the Dean's fight it out it's their
problem okay you know I'll go where you
know it's intellectually best for for me
to do it so that those the kinds of
things are going to get fought out in a
lot of different ways so there's I think
it's been part of what I'm hoping to do
with the book and seems to be happening
and is to provoke a conversation because
the Provost has been having
conversations the librarians have the
lawyers have the individual disciplines
have the funding agencies have and we're
finally having that cross-cutting
conversation to say this affects
everybody and very different and often
unforeseen ways and if we're really
going to to capitalize on it move
forward we've got to have a new kind of
conversation so yeah back here in the
pink sign
always striking such events where I
learned an enormous amount with the
conversation and the research and that
the funding to investigate the issue
seems to come very early on of the
science community the conversation about
open access is driven by the problems
for science publishing for university
press nonprofits monographs business
it's it's very confusing part because
the solutions don't seem to address the
real problem
waise research in the humanities get
okay so again trying to trying to repeat
that is that so much of this the cyber
infrastructure movement it has been
driven by by the sciences and the needs
of the humanities and arts are without a
doubt considerably considerably
different and and how well they how will
they get met in this environment a fair
summary okay on the one hand I mean
you're absolutely right but that but
that's not unusual I mean if you go back
to the 1960s changes in scholarly
publishing that was also very driven by
the sciences and and you know the
humanities kind of trickled up the rear
similarly I'm part of what's happened is
old debates are bubbling more up to the
surface the library the library budget
was always skewed way toward the
sciences and as the as scientific
journals have gotten more and more
expensive the cuts have been to the
journals in other areas and and they've
been cuts to the monographs and so the
arts and humanities been have been hurt
even more in this environment but
because it's more obvious what's
happening I think again a different kind
of conversation is going on the I've got
some slides that I didn't use today but
there's a long discussion and in the the
chapter 8 I think it is undisciplined
documents and data where it really
compared that what's happening in in the
different areas to note that the
sciences have the shortest half-life of
use
you know that people tend to use things
when they're pretty new and yet the
online depth is the greatest the science
Citation Index goes all back to 1900 and
the social sciences have a flatter curve
but that goes back to 1956 the arts and
humanities things are notoriously out of
print before they're out of date that
only goes back to 1975 so you got a
complete reverse ordering as far as
what's available versus the patterns of
use so the business opportunity is to
get that longtail means to take the
Amazon and Netflix model and get that
longtail back up and available because
because because that's where the
humanities and arts are really going to
benefit and these mass digitization
projects are doing exactly that they're
getting much more the longtail up and
available so so potentially that's the
punchline is that the massive book
digitization projects will shift that
and make much more data available and if
you if you've seen Gregg cranes nice
little piece and delive magazine what do
you do with the million books yeah it's
just it's a nice little punchy pieces
well well you do entity extraction you
find the names and the places and the
people you do automatic translation
there's all kinds of things you could do
when you've got a million books online
okay so you ask us new questions and new
ways so I think that balance may be
shifting but against it's another kind
of conversation to be had here sir
I mean it image is a great example like
you say rather precarious faculty
positions and whether you've got tenure
or not you're not not in an easy place
right now with this that's a
conversation I think that's probably
taking place more within the disciplines
the Modern Language Association tried
some years ago it with great flames as I
recall of trying to get people to think
in terms of different kinds of
publishing increments rather than
monographs and it kind of went and kind
of went nowhere right so yes it's the
market right so it's the market push so
it's a different kind of pressure from
the outside and from the inside of what
you value because the peer review still
takes place within the discipline but of
course those are very fuzzy boundaries
of what of what the discipline is the
you know certainly the hope is this is
the open access is a more democratizing
way of getting multiple voices out and
giving people
more ways to publish because the you
know the subsidies to the academic
presses are basically gone nobody's
gonna nobody's going to publish that
jail 500 copies French literature piece
that you used to get your tenure anymore
so that these new models but but I think
that's very much about what you know
what is English willing to value in such
a way that it can get it can get the
credibility within the ten year in
review and hiring committees of that
community that that's a it's not an easy
one but but but how do you get data
valued in chemistry is it's not an easy
one either but it's a it's a different
it's a different commodity but I think
it's a similar kind of conversation
that's happening excellent question and
I don't envy you so the concise question
is is how do I see librarians roles
changing as more digital resources
that's not one with a concise answer of
course one is that we need librarians
more than ever
whether it is the mediation of finding
things or trusting things or or the
scent or the sense of authority
I see like I see librarians working at a
much wider range of roles through the
life cycle I mean historically
librarians came along at the point that
things pass through that peer review and
they got published and they got some of
the employment or of some publisher and
and then in the end you didn't buy them
until you had two good reviews and
credible sources and really high bars
but you knew what to trust
and now we've got librarians who need to
deal with the data at the very beginning
and even valuing what are those data in
working with the community to say what's
we're selecting what's worth appraising
what might get some use in the future
because we can't keep all of it and the
the preprints of what what might get you
know what
what should the University capture what
is the intellectual role of the
community and then that curation that
permit access all the way through that
value chain tying all the pieces
together that old idea of working
directly with the community that that
being an advocate it's not just going to
colloquia in the department it's about
working it at the front lines with with
with the people themselves so it's
anything it's a much if anything it's a
much broader role than we had before and
we need to teach people much more richly
about the whole scholarly process and
not just about what you do with things
after they get published because that's
the role doesn't start there anymore it
start the roles starts way way back here
and comes all the way through so we've
definitely needed a new generation with
it with a different array of skills and
the kinds of students that I've got out
here who really are working in the field
one of my students spent three weeks in
Peru and June with the seismic team
helping lay a lay a seismic transect all
the way across Peru and figuring out how
do you collect the data in man's day and
he's seen a done visualization tools for
it another one he keeps falling into
quicksand in other parts of the project
I mean that there really is literally
out there in the field with them that
they're learning they're learning how
the data get made and this is not
something that was certainly library
school when I went to library school
back when I think this is it's a
different world and need to be engaged
in new ways but I've nothing but open
opportunities for those of us who were
willing to jump into quicksand if we
need to okay she loved it by the way